is Microsoft was looking at what is
considered the harms that people are
saying and then trying to address that
and um what I feel is the Nintendo thing
we knew about right we already knew
about the relationship I think King is
on it as far as you know kind of feel
foreshadowing that was they had they had
a nice relationship with the switch on
the back of the um of the infamous desk
kind of thing and um you know to me it's
all about okay how could we show that we
are not trying to take this thing for
ourselves we're going to put it on more
platforms than it ever existed before
but I have to admit the Nvidia one
opened my eyes that was the one that
when I looked at it and I'm like okay
one of the things that I really feel
that the CMA FTC all these regulatory
bodies have against Microsoft that is
legit is you you potentially dominating
in a nascent Market a market that's new
it's emerging and we got to be real like
Azure is outside like Azure the
infrastructure is really large you know
what I mean